[Music]
as russia's war on ukraine continues
neighbouring moldova is looking
anxiously over the border for now
fighting is still some distance away but
with a pro-kremlin separatist enclave
already on its eastern flank moldova
remains vulnerable to vladimir putin's
longer-term ambitions for territory and
influence
we've been to find out why
while ukraine has been experiencing the
full horrors of a russian invasion
the neighbouring republic of moldova has
looked on in trepidation
the republic of moldova it is a rio of
interest of russian federation i cannot
neglect the military risk
it is also a former soviet republic
which russia wants to keep in its sphere
of influence
russia never stopped
its attempts to interfere mode of an
internal politics
it's why many moldovans fear they may be
next on vladimir putin's target list
if you ask if people are afraid are they
on alert yes of course they are
permanent alert
[Music]
this is a country with a troubled past
thirty years ago as the soviet union
began to disintegrate moldova was
ravaged by a bloody civil war
on one side were pro-independence
moldovans on the other a moscow minority
backed by elements of russia's 14th army
hundreds died and in 1992 the country
split on either side of the river
denisto leaving democratic moldova on
most of the west bank and on the east
bordering ukraine the breakaway enclave
of transnistria
an autocratic ethnic russian statelet
ever since through years of uneasy
ceasefire moldova has been the subject
of an ideological tug of war between
russia and the west
now having seen what putin is attempting
in ukraine many moldovans believe russia
is once again trying to undermine their
country
the most important side of this
destabilization is the fake news and the
propaganda
we under
a constant attack from
different
groups in the social media
let alone about the official media they
have
agents of influence
i speak about different political
parties like the party of socialists or
different political leaders important
one or even marginal
with small ratings in the society
they use narratives regarding war in
ukraine regarding
the situation of refugee in the
fear that it's all part of a bigger
kremlin plan
to extend russian hegemony along the
southern coast of ukraine and then
through and beyond transnistria into
their country as well
a lot of actors from russian federation
speak about
novorossia
which mean
from donetsk until odessa
they will create
a new state but they will not stop they
also speak about transnistria including
moldova
the president of belarus and close ally
of putin alexander lukashenko caused
uproar by showing that russia's invasion
map included not only ukraine but
moldova
we saw these military plans maps
so that was one more confirmation that
we should stay on alert
but it's the possible role that
transnistria might play in these plans
that's keeping many moldovans on edge
when the country split into two russia
maintained a peacekeeping military
presence in the breakaway enclave a
force that some now fear could be a
trojan horse in any invasion
[Music]
about the military potential in
transnational on land bank of nist there
is a operative group of russian troops
nearly
2500 something like that so
the danger of this military units it's
not exaggerated
estimates as to the size of
transnistria's own separate defense
force vary from between eight and twelve
thousand
and many of these are battle hardened
having already fought for russia we have
a lot of evidences of uh
of the uh persons from transnistria who
were enrolled for many years in
different private military
groups of russia who fought
on the side of the of the russia in
donbass starting from 2014.
to make matters even worse one of the
biggest arms dumps in europe is situated
in transnistria
according to the moldovan academy of
sciences should the arsenal comprising
20 000 tons of munitions ever come under
attack and explode it could have a false
equivalent to the nuclear detonation at
hiroshima
it's a major risk
this ammunition they are very old
nevertheless as with donbass and luhansk
in eastern ukraine putin has always been
at pains to emphasize transnistria's
links to the motherland
prejudice
but in march 2022 just days into the
ukrainian war moldovan president maya
sandu applied to take her country
her predecessor igor doden a
long-standing supporter of putin and now
the leader of the opposition decried the
decision ominously suggesting moldova
draws lessons from the situation in
ukraine
the ex-president of the country dadon is
start to be very talkative in his afford
to spread the whole russian narrative
all these discourse that actually nato
is guilty or ukrainians are guilty or
even public messages says
we have to to learn ukrainian lesson
which normally means otherwise putin is
going to invade us also
across the denista transnistrius
hardline leader valim krosnolselski was
also quick to condemn sandu's eu hopes
shumuldovans were surprised
indeed they point to taraspal
transnistria's soviet-era capital with
its legions of lenin's statues as a grim
example of what they would like to avoid
many transnistrians though seem happier
to imagine life under russian rule
since 2002
more than 200 000 of them have taken out
russian citizenship
the russian military doctrine we can
find this idea that we are
closed neighbors
republic of moldova and
ukraine and on this territory there are
the russian citizen
and they can use this doctrine to
introduce military troop on this
territory
many moldovans believe that this attempt
to build a narrative around safeguarding
russian citizens is merely to establish
a pretext for eventual aggression
a few weeks ago i think there was an
announcement made by the russian embassy
in kishino to which they said
please everybody who consider themselves
being discriminated on the basis of
russian language
call or write us at this
address
but if russia hasn't yet been able to
make good on its plans for moldova it's
still difficult for anyone to ignore the
conflict in ukraine
in this region people used to routinely
cross borders to work or to see family
and friends
now the traffic is mostly just one way
in the second or third day when the war
erupted
the president of the country has
announced that molova is open for
refugees
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians have
crossed into moldova
passing through the unhcr camp at
palanca
roman malonsia who lives in the nearby
village of tudora regularly comes to the
camp to see if he can help
he has even given a home to families
fleeing the war
the first people who came said that they
were just afraid
the people who come now
they wanted to
stay
but when they see bombs
close to their house
then they understand that they must find
a safer place for children
for
grandchildren
svetlana and her family escaped from the
southern ukrainian city of micholiev
which saw intense fighting and nearly
fell to the invaders
actually spread
some of the ukrainians who fled here at
the start of the war are now helping
others get out behind them nikolai
shevchenko who escaped with his family
routinely ferry's new arrivals to the
capital kissin
and
[Music]
foreign
once in the capital refugees are housed
either in people's homes or at places
like this an exhibition center
in the first days of the refugees being
here we observed in a surprising
situation for us when people
regardless the language they speak they
all united around the refugees and
organize different volunteering
groups
half of the reason i was i started doing
that is just to feel
safe with a community of people and to
share our fears to share our anxieties
because it was a lot of panic in the
first days i mean people were leaving
moldova
meanwhile outside the russian embassy in
kisnap a daily protest encourages
passing cars to sound their horns in
solidarity with ukraine
diana derivienko is one of the regulars
[Music]
absolutely
working with the refugees has left diana
wanting to know more about their plight
so she's making the dangerous journey in
reverse
back across the border to the ukrainian
port city of odessa
or
she's come to meet local activists who
are helping to house those who've
escaped mariupol a city further east
where the fighting has been brutal and
civilians have struggled to find shelter
and food
foreign
odessa is less than an hour by car from
moldova
and most moldovans understand that where
the russian army to reach it there'd be
little to prevent them going further
we are conscious that
if ukraine will lose
odessa we are next
[Music]
moldova has not a military potential to
defend itself
further down the coast from odessa
mikhailev has been repeatedly pounded by
russian artillery and missiles
the regional government were devastated
by a rocket attack that killed 12 people
and injured 20 others
so far odessa city hall has escaped that
fate but several missiles have landed
elsewhere
[Music]
with its opera house palaces and
theaters odessa is as graceful and
elegant as any european city
and it's long been a source of pride to
both ukrainians and russians
but if it comes under the sustained
bombardment that has devastated other
ukrainian cities it's hard to imagine
these architectural gems surviving
odessa journalist sergei dibrov is proud
of its historic buildings many of them
dating back from its imperial russian or
soviet eras but he says his city and his
country are no longer prisoners of the
past
ukrainians was in the situation of the
choice
in which side of the iron curtain
they will be and i see ukrainians
make their decision clear
they are fighting for europe now
[Music]
for now odessa is still standing
but the deadly rocket attacks haven't
stopped this one killed four civilians
and some analysts remain convinced that
the russians won't easily give up on
extending their offensive up to and over
moldova's border
if it gets even close to that aim then
the russian forces in transnistria could
still come into play
how long would it take for russian tanks
to get into the capital here
two or two or three hours it's not a
half a day it is two or three hours
when russia's invasion began on february
the 24th the possibility that these
troops seen here on routine training
could attack either east or west into
ukraine or moldova put both countries on
alert
that russia had also upgraded the
airport in transnistria's de facto
capital terraspol only increased the
unease
if you ask me can russian army
bring their planes there
i can't answer to you to this question
because you know two months ago i would
never suppose that russians would do
this
psychopathic
move and declaring war to the
to ukraine
if it came war would have devastating
consequences fumbled over
it's not a member of nato and its
application to join the eu has yet to be
approved
in the meantime it remains europe's
poorest country and though it would
surely get some help from the west
few think it could hold out militarily
if russia attacked
there's democracy here
a relatively free press and some respect
for human rights
but none of them would help much if the
tanks rolled in
neutrality for republican moldova it is
a good instrument but at the same time
we are weak we are vulnerable because
this neutrality
isn't recognized
many mulderbands say they already have a
good idea of what life would be like
should their country fall into moscow's
sphere of influence
they point across the river denista to
tarraspol where incredibly when the
russian invasion began it wasn't
mentioned on either of the two local
state-controlled tv channels for several
days
we use
the tv venues only with russian
propaganda
and there are no
independent media
in transistor region practically
even transnistria's elections held in
december 2021 were funded and monitored
by russia
pro-kremlin incumbent vadim krasnowski
was re-elected with the soviet-style
share of the vote of 87 percent
christina schelzky and so-called supreme
soviet it's a bandit authoritarian
regime
there are very few persons who are in
opposition but it's an
authoritarian regime
with so-called ministry of state
security
like kgb
so they still have the kgb yes including
the name
those who fall foul of the transnistrian
authorities can disappear
adrian glidgen was abducted
adrian was eventually charged with
treason but vera believed it was a way
to get at her for teaching children
about human rights
in recent years she's been taking
youngsters from the breakaway region
back over the border to the moldovan
village of sanatoka to mix with others
and learn in an environment free from
propaganda
is
[Music]
many parents are keen for their children
to receive a proper education
but when the school bell rings the
children have to return to transnistria
adrian's abduction is not an isolated
case
in a bizarre echo of north korea a
number of people have been abducted from
the moldovan side of the river and taken
back to be illegally detained in
transnistria
in some cases they
came here
in the civilian class police from
translational region
and kidnapping persons transported them
on the left bank of venistro
[Music]
was one of those targeted for opposing
the transnistrian regime
every moldovan has heard stories like
this
and so it's hardly surprising that they
are worried about what comes next
one of their greatest anxieties is that
with russia's invasion not going well
moscow might stage a false flag attack
in transnistria to drag moldova into the
war
this territory can be used as a
provocation for example incident
explosion
it's a major risk for republic of
moldova
in late april just days after natalia
alby made this prediction government
offices in transnistria and other
buildings in the enclave were attacked
with gunfire and rocket grenades
no one claimed responsibility for the
incident and there were no reported
casualties but quickly and perhaps on
cue one of vladimir putin's top generals
rostam minnekev made this statement
control over the south of ukraine is
another way out to transnistria
where there are cases of
russian-speaking people being oppressed
[Music]
for now that peace still holds
but moldova remains vulnerable
how when and why the war in ukraine will
end remains uncertain but for as long as
the killing continues no one here can
feel safe
everything is possible yes under this
uncertain circumstances everything is
possible
in late may after this film was
completed the head of moldova's
pro-russian opposition party former
president igor dodon was arrested on
corruption charges